this series will decide playoff
positioning for both of these teams
and dylan cease is ready to throw it's
tony this is our final series of the
year in the regular season
it is that and hopefully dylan starts it
off on the right foot and the 2-2 pitch
ground ball made for two madrigal will
flip to short for one anderson's return
throw is going to be in time
yes indeed they turn it 4-6-3 and the
double play will end the inning here in
the first
you darvish shot for his 12th start he's
7-3 era of 222.
a lot of strikeouts 88 of them he's got
very good control only 13 walks
tim to right field that's a base hit to
open the game for the sox
sox need to get on the board early and
put some pressure on the cubs who know
they're not scoring a lot of runs two
and two on ground all switch hitter
batting left-handed darvish is ready
right-hander fires a swing and a miss
that was not in a great location but it
had some good break to it ron and he got
away with it and
strikes out abreu hits a high pop fly
it's more of a
fly ball toward right near the line is
going to be jason hayward he'll make the
catch
and that ends the end two down here is
kyle schwarber
schwarber with 10 home runs there'd be
no reason for him
not to try for a home run in this spot
he drives this one in the air deep left
field back as the left fielder angle at
the wall leaping home run
opposite field home run kyle schwarber
cubs lead one to nothing
the only run cece has allowed to the
cubs have been
two kyle schwarber home runs two on with
one out for a dangerous guy and anthony
rizzo two and two
he struck him out good slider from dylan
sees two gone
so two away two on and it's up to wilson
contreras
now the 1-1 contrast drives one in the
air right field deep that ball's got a
chance
it's gone opposite field three-run
homer wilson contreras hubs lead four to
nothing
as contreras flipped his bat high in the
air he flipped that bat about 30 feet in
the air
swinging a miss strike three and the
inning has come to an end our 15th out
javi baez will lead off flying out to
right field his first and only time to
the plate
baez drives one in the air left center
field that balls back toward the wall
and
it is going to be gone for a home run
long gone by us with a rocket to the
seats and the cubs with their third home
run of the night and they lead by a high
five here at guaranteed right field
three and one ride drive tim goes to
snare it oh what a play
sprawling by seven for round number two
nothing into the count and that pitch is
strike three called high in the zone
and the inning is over kidneys can't
believe it one out and here is
edwin encarnacion batting yeah the one
two to encarnacion
strike three called on the inside corner
and carnacion thought it curved around
the plate he's arguing with dan bellino
to no avail that's a strikeout and it's
the third strikeout for darvish
curveball big chop right side glove by
rizzo he'll take it over and stomp on
the bag
three unassisted inning over cubs five
white sox nothing
bases loaded for javier baez who homered
is last time up
and a first pitch swing and a chopper
towards short anderson off-balance throw
gonna be in time across the diamond
and the cubs leave the bases loaded in
the top half of the fifth inning
billy hamilton at first base switch
hitting caratini batting right-handed
waiting for the 3-2 pitch
and he drives one in the air right field
pretty well hit back goes missouri to
the walk on
first homer of the year for victor
caratini and the cubs lead
seven to nothing garvish out for what
might be his final
inning of work for the game and the o1
from darvish
fastball line drive deep right center
but playable for hayward
jason grabs it for out number two jake
kind of ducking down maybe to block the
lights out of his eyes power against
power here comes the next delivery
current ball swinging a miss strike
three darvish strikes out abreu
white sox going over here in the sixth
after six innings to play it's the cubs
seven the white sox nothing contreras
had arguably the biggest blow of the
game a three-run homer in the third
as that one hits contreras after the
home run and the bat flip earlier
the cubs dugout is
yelling at cordero dan valeno says stay
in the dugout everybody
the umpires are going to come together
and they'll talk it over
contreras gets hit by the pitch and
they're going to throw out cordero
ricky rancheria comes out to argue and
coop is back there too
don cooper thrown out of the ball game
by the way yeah i figured that was i
mean as he was keeping the argument
going
it's the cubs eight and the white sox
nothing they waste robert
one for two with a single swinging a fly
ball right field should be routine for
hayward
it's a one two three inning for you
darvish
seven shutout innings for the cubs right
handed they're loaded with one away
now the one two to half swinging a fly
ball
shallow center racing in robert still
coming makes the catch
tagging is caratini the throat of the
plate carotene is
safe the ball is jarred loose a run is
in
abraham picks up the ball kepnes runs to
third he's safe
horner goes to second pubs get a run
here's yomer sanchez making his major
league pitching
debut and contreras hits one deep to
right there she goes
10 to nothing he's homer twice tonight